Hello friends and welcome to your
program 3abn today Bible q a my name is
idalia denzi and it's a privilege for me
to share this following hour with you
I'd like to invite you to just grab
something to write on something to write
with because we're going to address your
questions and you're going to be blessed
with the answers because they are Bible
answers well I'd like to present to you
our panel for this program to my right
is Pastor John lomak and Pastor welcome
good to be here Tita always a joy to
walk through God's word and find answers
to the questions that will bring people
closer to Christ thank you Pastor thank
you it's always a privilege to be around
Pastor he's always teaching us there at
the Thompsonville Seventh-day Adventist
Church our local pastor and we have
Daniel Berlin welcome thank you always
glad to be here every Bible question is
another invitation to see what God has
to say that's right and we thank you so
much for all the you do in the Pastoral
Department here at 3abn I'm sure our
family at home is anticipating your
answers and of course my favorite
Speaker John Dempsey welcome I think
you're biased it's a blessing to be here
and we Rejoice to know that we have
God's word that is a light onto our feet
and our path amen amen I'd like to thank
you also because you have been a good
teacher a spiritual teacher to our
children and to myself in our home thank
you for your leadership so I am
surrounded by Godly men men that love
God's word and you know it's a privilege
to pull together and work together as a
family and to you guys I think you may
have noticed some flowers on the set
these are very very special flowers it's
a special flower arrangement that was
sent to me by my sister Grace my sister
in Christ from London she said and these
flowers so I just want to send you a big
hug and thank you thank you for always
supporting us for your prayers and your
company here at 3abn well before we
continue or for us to continue we'd like
to pass and pray for the Lord to guide
our program here and also for your heart
too so you can receive God's message for
you let's bow our heads together father
God it's a privilege for us to come
before your throne of grace the almighty
all-knowing God thank you for your mercy
thank you for your faithfulness thank
you Father that you have left a manual
for us and you have left your word to
fill our hearts you are Our Hope
you are our
Fortress so we seek you now through your
word to see your love on being unfolded
for us as it unfolds as the answers are
given to us we pray father that our
hearts will be at peace and that we will
trust you trust your word and be ready
for your soon return in Jesus name we
pray and we thank you for being with us
amen and amen amen okay guys you ready
Pastor Loma King okay you're first
we Christians have a sinful nature
within us but when we get to heaven will
that sinful nature disappear this is an
email from Ronda in Minnesota wow well
you know this is a a lengthy question
and I thank the Lord that um it could be
very to the point so let me just go
ahead and share with you what the Bible
says you know will our sinful nature
disappear before we get to heaven or
when we get to heaven well you know when
we accept Christ Our sinful nature is
dealt with immediately you know II Peter
1 verse 4 talks about that transition it
says by which we have been given by
which have been given to us exceeding
great and precious promises that through
these you may be partakers of the divine
nature so when we accept Christ there's
a nature change immediately the thing
that changes gradually is the way we
used to live our habits God begins to
condition and teach us differently
because we have been saved from the
penalty of sin you know first John 1 9
if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and
cleanse us from all unrighteousness so
our past is dealt with but the nature
aspect
the way we thought the way we lived the
way we did life the things we thought of
in the past before accepting Christ
those are all a part of the process of
sanctification so if you're talking
about maybe your habits and your
Lifestyles and your practices we are
walking in a new life and you know
Philippians 1 6 the Lord says he who has
begun a good work and you will complete
it so the Lord comes to uh if you could
think of a construction project somebody
buys a broken down house and then my
wife and I like House channel
HGTV and they see these homes we think
what are they going to do what what
would they do with that house right well
not only are we wowed maybe a half hour
later when they say or many years ago
Extreme Home Makeover move the bus yes
we think is that that prior house I mean
how on Earth could they have done that
the changes are not just external the
changes are internal and the Bible says
in Romans 6 6 knowing this that our own
man was crucified with him that the body
of sin might be done away with that we
should no longer be slaves to sin so
that change that's the change that takes
place immediately the breaking of the
chains that held us in our past that's
called
justification and then we enter into the
process of daily being saved from the
power of sin which is called
sanctification Romans 6 14 for sin shall
not have dominion over you for you are
not under the law but on the grace
doesn't mean not under God's
Commandments that still stands that's
the Magna Carta of our living but it
means you're no longer under the law of
sin and death which controlled your
prior behaviors and then finally the
Lord caps it off when he returns and
gives us immortality gives us
incorruptibleness so we're not going to
go to heaven with the possibility of
being corrupted again because we put on
incorruption and that's Isaiah 25 verse
9. and it will be said in that day
behold This Is Our God we have waited
for him and he will save us that's the
final aspect of sealing our character in
Christ amen amen thank you so much
Pastor Daniel are you ready for your
first question because we are at the
edge of our chairs we got a text and
this is the coming that came in I came
across a verse in the Bible that had me
perplexed the verse in Genesis 11 31 is
this verse saying Tara not Abraham left
the land of Earth first if this is true
terrorists life certainly influenced his
son Abram's decision to leave haran when
God called so in essence Abram didn't
leave ER he left haran okay parents are
an influence on their children and I
want to share with you three of the four
texts that deal with that mention Ur of
the chaldees Genesis chapter 11 Tara had
three children and Abram nahor and Heron
and haran and Heron had a son named lot
and verse 31 says Tara took his son
Abram and his grandson lot haran had
already died there in uh in Ur the
chaldees and it says they went out from
Ur of the Chaldeans to the land of
Canaan they came to Heron and dwelt
there and then Tara died there inherent
so Tara did leave but it was Abram the
Bible says who is responding to the call
of God Genesis 12 1 says now the Lord
said to Abram get out of your from
your country from your family from your
father's house to a land I will show you
so scripture doesn't report on a command
that God had given to Tara that he heard
and obeyed though he still may have been
indeed been responding to the prompting
of God in fact Tara seems to be holding
on to family customs and perhaps
actually building a settlement and
naming it there haran after his son who
had died Abram though is the one who
left and continued in obedience listen
to what Genesis 15 Verse 6 and 7 says he
believed in the Lord and he counted it
to him for righteousness then God said
to him I am the Lord who brought you out
of the land of UR of the chaldees all
right so it is God who gets the glory
god is the one who is prompting this he
brought Abram out or the chaldees was in
the Fertile Crescent so is haran and so
uh uh Tara Tara he went to haran stayed
in the Fertile Crescent there and it was
Abram the one who left the land of
production the land of familiarity the
land of flourishing uh places like that
so God who gets the glory Nehemiah
chapter 9 verse 7 in retail in the
history says the same thing that God
brought him out of UR of the chaldees so
here's the obedience here it is Genesis
12 verse 4 so Abram departed as the Lord
had spoken to him so the Bible looks to
Abram as the one who was responding in
obedience to the call of God God Hebrews
11 8 making it perfectly clear by faith
Abram obeyed when he was called to go
out to the land or to the place which he
would receive as an inheritance so Tara
did go out but Abram is the one who
obeyed Abram is the one who not only
went out but went to the place that God
had showed him and God had commanded
here him so there is a Biblical
principle of parents opening the way and
we do see Tara doing that and so parents
out there who are listening consider
your example and open the way for your
children but then also make sure that
you obey too that you go where you're
supposed to go so I hold my bike the
bike seat of my child as he or she is
learning how to Pedal But ultimately as
I prepare the way they've got to put
their feet on the pedals and they've got
to do what is right before God that's
right amen thank you so much Daniel John
Dempsey why does Seventh-Day Adventists
adhere to certain laws like eating clean
animal well not others like mixing
Fabrics
it seems like Messianic Judaism Judaism
as acceptance and acknowledgment of
Christ however still observing Jewish
practices Jacoby from Oklahoma sent us
text
thank you very much this is an
interesting question and Seventh-Day
Adventists are not like Messianic use
there are differences so the question is
why and so uh I point you to some
differences
the Ten Commandments were given to all
people we're not just given to the Jews
or Messianic Jews for example God does
not only tell the Jews that you shall
not kill you shall not murder you should
not commit adultery The Ten Commandments
are for all people
so this is why The Seventh-Day
Adventists keep the Ten Commandments by
God's grace now the Jews and Messianic
Judaism they observe about
613 oral laws that The Seventh-Day
Adventists do not the Messianic Jews and
Jews also observe the feast days which
include the Passover Feast of Weeks rash
Hashanah which is the traditional Jewish
New Year the Feast of trumpets Yom
Kippur which is the day of atonement the
Feast of Tabernacles Etc Seventh-Day
evidence do not keep the East Messianic
Jews keep it to some modified form
so Seventh-Day Adventists do not observe
this feasts why because these feasts all
pointed to Christ and when Christ died
on the cross there's a clear indication
given that the feast days and ordinances
and the sacrifices were done away you
can go to Matthew chapter 27 and read
there that when Jesus Christ is on the
cross there is the veil torn into
America a miracle because it was from
the top to the bottom which was very
high this was not done by human hands
this is a clear indication that these
ordinances since these days were done
away because Christ had died on the
cross and so Seventh-Day Adventists do
not keep these because Jesus Christ has
done put that away
now I want to talk about the what you
pointed to clean animals and unclean why
does having the evidence do that because
in First Corinthians 6 19 and 20 the
Bible says or do you not know that your
body is the Temple of the Holy Spirit
who is in you whom you have from God and
you are not your own is this something
only for the Jews is this something only
for the Messianic Judaism are they the
only ones that are the the body the
Temple of the Holy Spirit no this is
also for all of God's people all who
want to follow him and this is why it
says in verse 24 you were bought with a
price therefore glorify God in your body
and in your spirit which are Gods we are
by God's grace to keep our body in the
most possible healthy condition because
our body is the Temple of the Holy
Spirit and this is why we choose not to
eat the unclean animals that you can go
to Leviticus chapter 11 for example and
I see there the list of unclean animals
or the identification marks that tell
you which animals are clean and which
animals are unclean so this is why
Seventh-day Adventist understanding that
our body is the Temple of the Holy
Spirit do not eat the unclean animals
now if you choose to eat meat then you
should do eat the clean animals because
the unclean animals are those that are
most detrimental to your health and we
should keep away from that because our
body is the Temple of the holy spirit so
it's it's not just the Messianic Jews
and the Jews that are the Temple of the
holy spirit all of God's children God
calls them to be the Temple of the Holy
Spirit and that's why Seventh-Day
Adventists observe the Ten Commandments
and the not to eat the unclean animals
and so this there are some differences
and the Messianic Jews keep the feast
days in some modified forms we do not
keep the feast days because Christ has
fulfilled us so there are differences
and so I encourage you to continue
studying and and see that we are
presenting things from God's holy word
amen thank you so much well uh folks I
would like to con share the contact
information because this program is for
you we want to hear from you and I'm
sure by this time you are thinking I
have a question too or some of the
answers have perhaps
provoked another question so I'd like
for you to send us your email at bibleqa
at
3abn.tv as you see it on the screen
Bible QA at
3abn.tv once again Bible QA at
3abn.tv you can send us your text at
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 and of course
you can find us on social media
Instagram 3abn
underscore official and you can send
your comments there
so now we continue with Pastor John
lawmaking pastor this is a very special
question it hits home is it okay to be
an organ donor Dixie in Indiana you
might want to explain why it's a special
question I want to refer to you give you
a little bit about that time because my
my answer is very short you might want
to say why it's special to you oh
because I had the privilege of being 100
match as if we were identical twins with
my older brother to donate my kidney and
he had another chance at life amen 20
back in 2001 okay so the answer is yes
I'm going to answer on your behalf the
answer is yes it is okay to be an organ
donor some people do it while they're
alive some people indicate on their
driver's license or in special
Arrangements if anything were to happen
to me and we've heard people say well
kidney I've even heard some places where
people said uh uh wow their eyes their
pupils it's amazing how God has made our
bodies every aspect of it I know one
person talked about how many how many
specialized Physicians there are just to
deal with from the neck up I know you
know the ear nose and throat ENT that's
right then you have ophthalmologists and
optometrists for the eyes then you have
dentists for the mouth and then you have
surgeons for the brain and then you have
neurologists to understand how the mind
works it's amazing just from the neck up
there's so many Specialties one doctor
is not trained to do the other he says
well you need a dentist well isn't it
for my neck up don't you deal with that
well no there's so many things that
happen just from that area and we have
our hands now I've never heard of hand
donations but I know that the organs
that keeps a person alive my sister was
a benefactor of a a kidney that's right
she needed a kidney and praise the lord
it's been mild maybe almost eight to ten
years now and in many cases it doesn't
last but three four years and she's been
amazingly blessed it was also a
turnaround in her life because prior to
that working for the five Department of
New York City she was an EMT but she was
smoking at the time
occasionally but just not at all and
they said to her well to get this kidney
we're not going to give it to you if
you're still smoking that's right she
quit and just a few days ago we were
talking she said I can't even stand the
smell of smoke anymore and I don't let
anybody smoke in my cars or even around
me it's amazing how the body heals
itself yeah so yes it's okay to be an
organ donor and one of the challenges I
had was finding a scripture for this I
haven't shared with Daniel that says
maybe the one that I would use is it is
more blessed to give than to receive but
then again there are people that have
given organs
they're people that receive organs and
uh kidneys uh the one thing that you
can't transfer is your mind your brain
that is the central focal point but the
Lord is the only one that can do that
and this is when I'll make it a
spiritual application when we come to
Christ we get new organs amen he says in
Ezekiel 36 26 I will give you a new
heart and put a new spirit within you I
will take the Heart of Stone out of your
flesh and give you a heart of Flesh
Jesus believes in organ donorship and if
it were not for him I'd have that same
old heart thank the Lord that when I get
heartburn it's for the right reason did
not my heart burn within me when I read
the word of God so yes it's okay to be
an organelle amen thank you Pastor our
next question is addressed to Daniel and
this is from Heather in Canada I want to
thank you heather for taking the time to
send in your question my question is
about repentance she says from my
understanding repentance is when you are
truly sorry and emotionally upset about
the sin that you have committed I pray
and ask forgiveness for my sins but
sometimes I feel that I don't have that
heartfelt sorrow and feel that it is not
true repentance how do I get true
repentance I am serious about eternity
and I'm concerned that if I have
naturally repented that I will not make
it to Eternity with Jesus please help me
understand this process of repentance
okay not a sincere question it is and to
repent we need to love the law of God
if I do not love God's law I'm not going
to have sorrow for sin for breaking
God's law and this is why we don't tend
to cry when we break the speed limit
because we do not love that law the
psalm Psalm 19 verse 7 says the law of
the Lord is perfect have you ever seen
something perfect that you just want to
gaze into and study more and learn more
about it a perfect thing I mean what
what more could you ask for than to have
every detail every specific in
accordance with what is right
Psalm 1 verse 2 says that the one who is
blessed is going to be the person who
meditates upon God's law day and night
they love coming back and looking into
it because the law of God shows us his
character it Reveals His mind it shows
us what is what he is who he is it came
from him and as we look into God's law
we see the perfect beauty of God and who
he is
and as we look at God's perfect Beauty
revealed in his law we begin to see our
sinfulness by comparison and we begin to
see how different we are from God and
what changes he wants to make in our
life to elevate us and to change our
life so they look like his and so as we
as we see our sinfulness revealed God
reveals to us his solution which is
Grace Grace that not only covers our sin
and forgiveness but Grace that gives me
strength to keep God's law to obey what
he asks of us and so I want to
experience more of God's grace in my
life so I go back to the law and I read
God's word I study it and so because of
my sin God wants to Lead Me To the Cross
that's where I need to go each of the
gospels tells the story of the Cross
they don't all tell the story of Jesus
birth or some other things but each one
tells the story of the cross of Jesus
who in heaven experienced the perfect
adoration and praise of all the Angels
but he came down here lowered himself
humiliated himself to become one with us
walking through the sins of this world
the sins of my life and he lived a
perfect sinless life not a single
thought perfect love and he offers to be
my friend and then I see my friend go
into the cross people spitting on him
ripping out his hair in his beard
slapping him and him looking at people
with love and saying father forgive them
and as he's stretched down on the cross
I then have to take my sins by my choice
and I place them on my friend
is he then suffers for what I have done
and when I see what my sin does to Jesus
then I say Lord I don't ever want to
hurt you I don't want to be the one
because each of my sins is a nail
piercing it is part of the crown of
thorns and it is a whip
so study these texts here Psalm 51 the
whole Psalm but verse 2 and 3 Wash Me
thoroughly from my iniquity cleanse me
of my sin for I acknowledge my
transgression my sin is always before me
Romans 7 13 says that sin through the
Commandments that's the law becomes
exceedingly sinful in other words
exceedingly painful and I want to feel
that pain so that way I can say Lord
take my sin cleanse me of it Psalm 119
hold the whole Psalm but verse 136 says
rivers of water run down from my eyes
because men do not keep your law
Psalm 139 says search Me O Lord the last
two verses and try me search my heart
know my anxieties and see if there is
any wicked away in me and Lead Me in the
way Everlasting and so I say Lord this
book that I'm reading this movie that
I'm watching this hobby that I have
these thoughts that I'm thinking are any
of them those things that pierce the Son
of God and I say Lord help me to make a
clean break from those help me to detest
them and hate them the way you do I want
to hate sin as you do because I love you
and then like Paul first Timothy 1 15 I
will say Christ came into the world to
save Sinners of whom I am the chief o
Wretched Man that I am who will rescue
me from this body of death
thanks to the Lord to to God through
Jesus Christ Our Lord that's repentance
love the law of God and meditate on the
cross amen amen amen thank you so much
Daniel
well our next question Noah from India
thank you for the email you sent in if
Jesus Christ faced all trials John
Dempsey and Temptations in human form
how was he able to fast for 40 days
according to look forward to wasn't he
hungry during the 40 days as a human
Noah wants to know well I would be
hungry myself
well this is a good question and the
answer is with the help of God the
Father
please understand that let's go ahead
and read Luke chapter 4 verse one and
two it says there then Jesus being
filled with the Holy Spirit returned
from the Jordan after he was baptized
and was led by the spirit Into the
Wilderness he was drawn by the Holy
Spirit Into the Wilderness and it says
they're being tempted for 40 days by the
devil and in those days he ate nothing
and afterward it's interesting the way
it's worded and afterward when they had
ended he was hungry so it gives us an
indication that during that time
hung an interest for food was not there
he was in deep communion with God the
Father looking at the mission before him
in deep communion and says afterwards he
was hungry and was he hungry and that's
when the devil came to tempt him in his
weakest uh condition and you can read
that in Luke chapter four but
as we look at this question asking about
Jesus how was he able to do this the
Bible identifies three people that
lasted 40 days without food Jesus being
one of them I point you now to Moses in
Exodus chapter 34 verse 27 and 28 it
says there then the Lord said to Moses
write these words for according to the
tenor of these words I have made a
covenant with you and with Israel so he
was there with the Lord 40 days and 40
nights now notice it says he neither ate
bread nor drank water and he wrote on
the tables of the words of the Covenant
The Ten Commandments now it is a fact
that people can only last for three to
five days without water how was Moses
able to last 40 days without drinking
any water with the help of God and in
the same manner Jesus was able to last
40 days and 40 nights without eating any
food so we have another person that we
want to point to you and it's First
Kings chapter 19 verse 7 and 8. and this
is Elijah and it says here and the angel
of the Lord came back the second time
and touched him and said arise and eat
because the journey is too great for you
so here Rose and Nate and drank and
noticed and he went in the strength of
that food 40 days and 40 nights as far
as horb the Mountain of God so for 40
days and 40 nights Elijah did not eat
anything how was he able to do this with
the help of God and it seems that God in
moments of deep communion with him can
even
bless you so that you are not hungry
and this is what happened with Jesus
that's how he was able to do it and so
by God's grace amen thank you thank you
so much let's go to Pastor lawmaking
Pastor Tracy from Tennessee sent in a
text and we thank you Tracy for taking
the time Are there specific prophecies
we must know to inherit the kingdom of
God second Corinthians 5 17 says if any
man be in Christ he is a new creation
how do we know we are dwelling in Christ
is it a physical or spiritual change or
just a change of the heart okay well
thank you so much for that question
Tracy let's start with the prophecy
aspect of it and this is my four minute
question
there are no specific prophecies that we
need to know to inherit the kingdom of
God the purpose of Prophecy is to
indicate how close we are to the return
of Jesus you know Isaiah 46 verse 9 and
10 I call this the super prophecy for
the reason is it says remember the
former things of old for I am God and
there is no other I'm God and there is
none like me look at the super prophecy
declaring the end from the beginning and
from ancient times things that are not
yet done so prophecy itself covers the
entire scope of human existence from the
beginning the Lord declared things that
are going to take place in the end and
when he gave these words to Isaiah the
prophet things that have not yet been
done and he says my counsel shall stand
and I will do all my pleasure so
prophecy indicates that while men are
involved in the Avenues of Life the
economic the social the spiritual the
mental God really in fact is not pulling
the strings but there's nothing that men
can do to prevent the words of God from
being fulfilled you know Revelation 18
talks about how
God put it in their minds to fulfill his
will and so we find that prophecy the
purpose of Prophecy is to help us to
understand like Daniel in Revelation the
key books of Prophecy where we are in
the course of human history so when
Daniel says in the time of the end we
know that okay based on these signs
we're living in the time at the end when
Jesus says uh this know also well Paul
this know also that in the last days
perilous times will come and he
describes the conditions we know where
in the last days that's the purpose of
Prophecy but to inherit the Kingdom we
are not saved by prophecy we are saved
by Jesus and so there are some people
that don't know these prophecies but
they know Christ and by getting to know
Christ then he will later on as he said
to his disciples have many things to say
to you now but you can't handle them you
can't bear them I believe that in time
he will reveal to them what they need to
know but here's the foundation first
John 5 verse 12 he who has the son has
life he who does not have the son does
not have life what happened when we have
the son
the life we lived is no longer the life
we're living Galatians 2 20 I have been
crucified with Christ it is no longer I
who live but Christ who lives in me and
watch this and the life I now live in
the flesh I live by faith in the Son of
God who loved me and gave himself for me
so not only is he covering the sin of my
past but he becomes the substitutionary
sacrifice he goes to my cross he pays
for my sin and then he gives me his life
it is no longer I who live but Christ
who lives in me but how do we know that
we have entered into that life First
John 3 verse 14 we know that we have
passed from Death to life because we
love the Brethren he who does not love
his brother abides in death a clear
indication how do you feel to other
people people that you work with people
that you worship with your family
members now we don't have to love the
things they do but love is of God first
John 4 8 who does not love does not know
God for God is love so we have to
understand that our attitudes the fruit
of the spirit that's why the Bible says
in Matthew 7 verses 15 to 14 to 17 you
will know them by their fruits a loving
person you can't be too loving you can't
be too kind you can't be too
long-suffering you can't go to jail for
being too kind and so Christians should
be the kindest the most loving
individuals and people will say there's
something different about that person
why you have passed from Death to life
and then the physical impact
Romans 2 Romans 12 verse 1. I besee you
therefore Brethren by the mercies of God
that you present your bodies as a Living
Sacrifice holy and acceptable to God
which is your reasonable service the way
you treat your body from this point on
causes God to be the person that you
believe you are accountable to the
spiritual and physical effects of being
born again amen thank you thank you
Pastor Daniel
Caesar from Florida asks what does the
bible mean by the face of God did Moses
really see his face okay all right and I
will start out with Matthew 28 verse 4
where we have one Angel just a single
Angel who comes down to roll away a
stone and the Roman soldiers become like
dead men so if one Angel Bears the glory
that that knocks people down the face of
God must be something when unobstructed
that is powerful and it's no wonder the
Bible calls God a consuming fire John
chapter 4 verse 24 Jesus speaking says
that God is spirit and those who worship
Him must Worship in spirit and Truth in
other words God does not have a physical
body that can be seen by us John 1 18
says no one has seen God at any time the
only begotten son who is in the bosom of
the father in other words in close
intimate relationship he has declared
him
in other words Jesus revealed God by
speaking by declaring by demonstrating
it is the word that reveals who God is
that is his face the testimony of truth
so not a physical body but the character
revealed in Jesus so what did Moses see
Exodus 33 verse 11 says so the Lord
spoke to Moses face to face as a man
speaks to his friend and he would return
to the camp but his servant Joshua son
of none the young man did not depart
from the Tabernacle and so this here is
an expression of closeness and intimate
friendship speaking face to face as a
person talks to a friend and so that
means there was nothing between them God
spoke directly and clearly in Numbers
chapter 12 verse 8 the same expression
is usually translated face to face but
it literally is mouth to mouth and he
says I did not speak in dark sayings
that God spoke clearly to Moses and this
was good to the people of Israel but
because Moses was interceding for them
on behalf of their sin and they see God
communicating with their intercessor
well who else did God speak face to face
with like this Deuteronomy chapter 5
verse 4 Moses recounting the history of
Israel says the Lord talked with you
face to face on the mountain from the
midst of the fire and what did God speak
when he spoke face to face he gave his
law and so when God communicates himself
face to face it is his law that he gives
and Moses then wants to see God and so
he says after God had responded to his
intercession on behalf of the sins of
Israel at the golden calf Exodus 33 18
Moses says please show me your glory and
God says I will make all my goodness
pass before you all right he says I will
proclaim the name the Lord before you I
will be gracious to whom I will be
gracious and I will have compassion on
whom I will have compassion but he said
you cannot see my face for no one shall
see my face and live so he takes Moses
up there and he shows him and this is
what Moses sees when he sees God Exodus
34 says the Lord God made as good his
past before him and declared the Lord
the Lord God merciful and gracious
long-suffering and abounding in goodness
and Truth keeping Mercy for thousands
forgiving iniquity and transgression and
sin by no means clearing the guilty and
so when God's face is seen it is his
character his perfect righteous
character amen amen oh I can just spend
all day listening to you guys answering
these questions well let's go to my
husband John Dempsey this question or um
came through our Instagram and is from
Ed is there the question is should
Christians believe in astrology or star
signs a lot of young people think the
Bible allows them and I think we need a
lot of Awakening in knowing the truth
about it what do you have to say about
this well thank you for sending in the
question I'm not sure how you say your
name edister perhaps you are correct we
do need an Awakening and we need to know
the true concern in this and I'm going
to share some ideas to help in this way
Christians should not believe or follow
astrology or star signs there's danger
this is one of the distractions of the
devil to get people to replace god with
something else you know by Nature's
Christian not Christian I mean people in
general are curious people and impatient
we want to know what's going to happen
in the future so we get impatient we
want to figure out we're going to go
here go there and some people turn to
astrology some people turn to Sidekicks
trying to figure out what's going to
happen with this situation but the Bible
tells us in Proverbs chapter 3 verse 5
and 6 trust in the Lord with all your
heart and lean not on your own
understanding in all your ways
acknowledge Him and He Shall Direct your
paths so God is in control
by understanding that God is in control
trusting in Him that he's going to work
out the best solution for our problems
we can live our lives knowing that God
has our best interest in mind he's going
to work out the best for us now I have
to say that there are some warnings
concerning astrology in the Bible now
some people practice this not knowing
that it is dangerous and it's a
distraction of the devil so we have to
keep that in mind but in Isaiah chapter
47 verse 13 and 14 the Bible says you
are worried in the multitude of your
councils let now the astrologers the
stargazers and the monthly
prognosticator stand up and save you
from what shall come upon you notice
behold they shall be as double the fire
shall burn them they shall not deliver
themselves from the power of the flame
it shall not be a cold to be worn by nor
a fire to sit by so this is a a
dangerous thing that the the Bible says
to keep away from this this has some
Pagan Roots now some people that
practice astrology say well I don't have
any interest in worshiping Idols I I
don't have any interest in Pagan things
I just want to know what's going on and
so this is why they're doing it some
some may say innocently but there is
danger in this and this is why we need
to trust in the Lord and keep away from
these things now according to
livescience.com notice this your zodiac
sign corresponds to the position of the
sun relative relative to constellations
as they appeared more than 2 200 years
ago
so this is what the signs are this is
how they were but two thousand two
hundred years ago and these things have
moved and this is why uh they're in this
website livescience.com and say in short
as you'll see below your zodiac sign is
not what you think it is and your
corresponding horoscope can't be right
because they're basing this on the
position that we're over 2 000 years ago
so this there's no truth in that there's
truth in God's word
amen thank you thank you so much okay DJ
from California thank you for sending in
your text this is the question and
Pastor lomach is going to answer based
on scripture pastor does the mark of the
beast Sunday the Sunday law happen first
or does the end of probation happen
first okay well thank you for the
question uh DJ I used to be a DJ but a
different kind the Lord delivered me
from that amen but this is a very
significant question a lot of times
people are looking for these signs to
indicate well when I see this this is
what I'm going to do I heard a lot of
people say well I'll come back to church
when the Sunday laws passed well we
can't wait for these signs these are
things that we know will come to pass
Revelation is such a book that I love
the study of the Book of Revelation and
we find Revelation 13 this country the
United States will enact
legislatively laws that will connect us
to the former powers of Europe the
powers of Rome of the Vatican and they
will inevitably bring about this law
that would restrict our freedom of
worship which will include the the
veneration of Sunday the first day of
the week which most Christians today
honor traditionally not based on the
scriptures but you find an answer to the
question directly
the Sunday law will be introduced first
before it becomes Universal it's going
to become standard here in America and
then it's going to become an impact to
the entire world now why is this so
necessary because a lot of people say
what is the mark of the beast and we
have prophesied for so many years the
indications of Revelation and the
prophecies that are contained there
when people begin to see these movements
start to take place then the voice of
God will become more obvious to those
who are in other churches and this is
where Revelation 18 verse 4 comes in
and I heard another voice from Heaven
saying come out of her my people lest
you share in her sins unless you receive
of her plagues who apostate Christianity
who the woman of Revelation chapter 17
come out of that form of worship that is
anathema to the truth and why because
these are the last opportunities for
people that are in false religious
movements to hear God's voice in the
Sunday law would come first so they say
wait a minute
they're really trying to force us to on
a Sunday now I understand the Bible's
Sabbath now it makes sense to me and why
is it important when these signs take
place to respond to God's voice
Revelation 18 verse 23 you'll find that
the word of God the lamp of a light or
the light of a lamp shall not shine in
you anymore and the voice of the bride
groom and bride shall not be heard in
you anymore for your merchants or the
Great Men of the Earth for by your
sorceries all the nations were deceived
God is saying when he calls us out of
false worship
respond because soon the light of God
the voice of God the voice of the
bridegroom will not be heard any longer
and those who ignore the voice of God
and just waiting for the signs so here's
the answer to the question Sunday law
will come first and then the mark of the
beast in in reverence for that will come
next and finally but here you could
avoid all that by making sure that today
Your Allegiance is to the god of Heaven
the one that is the true establisher of
The Commandments of God
so the probation
um part of the question was does the end
of probation happen first and the answer
was Sunday law comes first and then
probation after that exactly thank you
so much Pastor and Daniel
I have one more question from for you
and this is from Canada uh Lennox thank
you for sending in your text it says
here A friend of mine is telling me that
Adam was right right there beside Eve
when she took and ate the fruit but Adam
did not stop her he is basing this on
the last part of Genesis 3 6 which says
and did eat and gave also unto her
husband with her and he did eat I do not
like to get into discussions without any
biblical evidence and speak contrary to
the word of God can give can you give
some enlightening on this verse
I would love to and I love what you said
at the end we want our answers to come
from the word of God so let's go to the
text Genesis chapter 3 verse 6.
so when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eyes and a tree desirable to make
one wise she took of its fruit and ate
now here we see a clue that Adam was not
by her side because in in the earlier
verses the serpent had addressed her and
only her and only she is the one here
who sees the tree and sees the fruit
good for food continuing on in the verse
6 so she gave to her husband with her
and he ate then the eyes of both of them
were opened and they knew that they were
naked they knew that they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves coverings So Adam was with
her when she gave him the fruit we know
that he wasn't standing with next to her
at the time of the deception because he
did not intervene Ecclesiastes 4 12 says
this though one may be overpowered by
another two can withstand them and a
three-fold chord is not quickly broken
had he been there at her side he would
have strengthened her and she would have
strengthened him because she was made as
his helper and he confessed her to be
bone of his bones and flesh of one of my
bones and Flesh of My Flesh they were
already meant to be together God had
made them to be one flesh and so that
for being with each other goes without
saying is what they were meant to be so
the statement that he was with her
indicates that he had not been with her
so he is now with her or rather along
with her uniting in her with her in the
same condition in the same experience
not indicating physical proximity but
that he had now United with her in sin
and Adam's sin was different from Eve's
first Timothy 2 14 says and Adam was not
deceived but the woman being deceived
fell into transgression Eve had been
deceived by the words of the serpent but
Adam was not deceived by those words
when the Temptation was presented to him
he saw clearly the stark contrast
between obedience that leads to life and
Disobedience that leads to death and
this is why Paul says God's speaking
here through the words of Paul in Romans
5 12 therefore just as through one man
sin entered the world death came through
sin and so it says that their eyes
together were opened when Adam sinned
God addresses Adam specifically when he
speaks to them because Adam's sin was
separate and different he was the one
through which sin entered the human race
and he bore guilt in a special way the
lesson here is that God has given us to
each other to strengthen each other
listen to Proverbs chapter 27 verse 17
as iron sharpens iron so a man sharpens
the countenance of his friend each one
of us should be the strengtheners and
helpers of those around us to resist
temptation hmm
then thank you so much Daniel and lastly
the last question for this hour
Buddha Pura texted and her question is
says I cremated my mom and dad and have
their ashes with me is this considered
not letting them rest in peace
thank you so much I see that you're
concerned about this and uh you have two
questions there so we'll talk about the
second one first there is no evidence in
the Bible that cremation is a sin none
uh you see in the Bible references to
people after they pass away that they
are buried this was the common practice
even among the Jews that you bury them
uh things were not established to burn
people now there are some history where
they show that people do would burn
their loved ones but this this was not a
common practice and this was not really
presented in the Bible as something that
would happen today there are modern
methods that make cremation possible
that are clean and that are effective
and it is in most cases less expensive
and this is why Christians and Jews are
choosing this to some degree so even
Jews and Christians are doing this again
it is not a the Bible does not mention
anything about it now concerning your
second question about not letting them
rest in peace I'm going to read to you
from Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5 and
6 and this is what the Bible says for
the living know that they will die but
the Dead
no nothing and they have no more reward
for the memory of them is forgotten so
uh the idea that you're disturbing their
peace it does not fit with what the
Bible says because the Bible says that
the the dead know nothing they do not
perceive anything you can come and bring
them flowers you can come and bring them
gifts they have no idea that this is
happening because they are in the grave
and the Bible calls this like a sleep
this is why Jesus said about Lazarus
when he died Lazarus is asleep and what
is he doing there he's
resting and in a sense not having any
activity notice what it says in
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse six also
their love their hatred and their Envy
have now perished neither will Nevermore
will they have a sharing anything done
under the sun they do not suffer they do
not have any sense of anything that is
going on they have no sense of time
passing by they have no idea if you came
to visit them they have no idea if you
brought them flowers they are not
Disturbed At All by by this so we have
also can take hope in understanding that
God is all-powerful and he can resurrect
us whether we were cremated or whether
we were put in the grave and by the slow
process of the chemical process that
takes place your bodies
it turns into ashes it turns into dust
and she says the dust to dust and Ashes
to Ashes so in essence either way you
become like dust and to God that makes
no difference he can resurrect you and
make you all new and as it was quoted
before this corruptable shall put on
incorruption this Mortal shall put an
immortality you're not disturbing their
peace amen amen well we're going to go
to a short pause and we will be right
back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
well we've been blessed and we thank the
Lord for this opportunity to have shared
this hour with you we do have some
closing thoughts from our panelists so
Pastor could you please yes I want to
encourage there's a number of questions
that have come here one to remind you
that yes you can donate your organ
somebody if that's the desire you have
but the thing about whether or not
there's a particular prophecy we need to
know before we are saved I tell you what
friends the best decision you can ever
make is to get to know Jesus and this is
life eternal that you may know him uh
when you know Christ then everything
comes into perspective but knowing all
that knowledge there's nothing more
fearful than knowing what's going to
happen and not knowing the man Christ
Jesus get to know him and all the fear
that you have will be moved away thank
you thank you Daniel yes we can't invent
and create emotion when we repent of sin
it only comes as a natural response to
our closeness with Jesus who is the face
of God listen to what he responded to
Philip when Philip said show me the
Father John 14 9 if you've seen me
you've seen the father amen amen and
John Dempsey thank you for those of you
that are concerned about what's going to
happen I like to remind you that the
blessing in Jeremiah 29 beginning verse
11 for I know the thoughts that I think
toward you says the Lord thoughts of
peace and not of evil to give you a
future and hope then you will call upon
me and go and pray to me and I will
listen to you and you will seek me and
find me when you search for me with all
your heart trust in the Lord he has
things in control and he will work out
the best for you amen amen thank you
thank you all for being men of the word
and man after God's heart I know thank
you and thank you folks at home continue
to send in your questions and comments
God bless
[Music]
thank you
foreign